beaucoup plus de gens nous connaissent
sonim là nicolas alors effectivement
aujourd'hui en m'accompagnant la map on
va parler du métier de youtube là vous
devez sûrement avoir beaucoup de
questions du moins j'espère pourquoi
zidane parle aujourd'hui pourquoi il
nous parle d'évolution
ça n'est pas un vrai métier ce qui fait
donc fait pas ça me dérange pas que
d'amour a commencé à lui beaucoup de
gens vendent 10 mais c'est pas vraiment
un métier ce que tu fais comment on
pourrait considérer quelque chose qui
est un métier qu'il soit utile à la
société
l'activité soit utile à la société on
sent bien le sens pas à l'aise et % à
l'adresse effectivement youtube c'est un
peu particulier comme
c'est nous qui a ses raisons mais qui
parle d'une passion la confédération
devient conteur fleuriste pourtant dans
une écriture
ça c'est dit se sentir bien
ça me va
se sentir utile à la société
le général pourtant pour beaucoup il
n'est toujours pas considéré expansion
kolawolé génération la génération z
aucun problème et qui est à venir est
effectivement une petite soeur
pour mes parents meetic
de l'armoire aux ménages ils adorent a
toujours votre jeu et c'est là la
différence et quelquefois avec le choc
des générations puisque youtube heures
au mexique
ça va demander les notions a demandé à
savoir plus globale ça demandait à
savoir plus globale effectivement
devient pas youtube heures et on objecte
apprendre un peu nous mêmes par exemple
quand vous voyez une personne qui va
jouer aux jeux vidéo pour vous c'est une
personne qui suit lé qui fait des
blagues devant jeu vidéo pourtant ça va
nécessiter un savoir prise d'image prise
de son du montage en une vidéo dynamique
et capter le spectateur sur sa vidéo
c'est souvent là le plus important sur
youtube c'est de faire en sorte que
cette personne reste sur ma nuque et on
pourra pas le comparer à jean pierre
pernaut c'est facile tout le monde la
nappe mais au-delà de ça sont des
vulgarisation métier il dit simplement
un prompteur rejeté pourtant non il a
toujours la petite blague la petite
anecdote le petit sujet qui lui est plus
ou moins et avec tout ça il ya créé un
personnage il capte notre notre notre
envie et avec ça il arrive à nous faire
rester sur son programme et qu on
pourrait le comparer à ça et récupère un
peu comme humoriste comme journaliers ou
ce genre de métier live en demandant à
savoir plus globale c'est un peu comme
si vous allez voir une suite de films -
humoristes ne savais pas si ça valait
quand vous y allez quand même vous
n'êtes pas seul et c'est là je trouve la
force de ce métier si je tombe
rapidement vous ennuie avec deux trois
statistiques faut savoir qu'en 2015
youtube devient la première plate forme
audiovisuelle en amérique devant la télé
devant netflix les chaînes de culture
les chaînes de sports rousseau volet
suivi après par là
de l'europe et donc de d'autres pays si
youtube prend de plus en plus de place
dans la société
les tueurs deviendra t'il pas un métier
où doit-on encore le considérer comme un
passe temps qui permet de faire il faut
savoir que comme pour le métier du cube
heures il ya plusieurs membres y
avait-il streamer on va se filmer en
direct en train de faire une action et
on va le diffuser sur internet ces
gens-là describing discret distribuer
pour ma part c'est le jeu vidéo vous en
doutez bien la danse classique s'est
légèrement compliqué et qu'on va parler
et je suis donc en live ces joutes sur
cet horaire régulier je prends l'antenne
et j'ai de 60 70 % du temps des
réguliers j'aime bien les appeler comme
ça c'est les gens qui viennent tous les
jours tous genres tout âge confondu
l'hymne regardant travaillant ça
plairait pas forcément lent poste il
regarde en étudiant il me regarde avec
leurs enfants qui est parent aussi pour
les rebelles semblent neige bref tout
genre d'activités ils ont tous dit la
même chose au bout d'un moment ils ont
aussi on vient plus pour ce que tu fais
comme je reviens pour la personne tuée
donc ça veut dire que je suis utile à
ces personnes si on fait la comparaison
est que le rôle d'un métier de dire que
mon activité de streamer laquelle un
métier où doit-on encore le considérer
comme un passe-temps jeux peuvent
rémunérer du c'est un peu ça la petite
particularité car ce genre de métier
d'ailleurs oui
dans la salle on peut gagner de l'argent
avec les jeux vidéo c'est notre âme
notre discipline qui fait que évolué
c'est devenir un joris porte donc
electronic sports
ce sont des athlètes qui s'affrontent
sur les jolies et déjà la jeune étudiant
athlète et jeux vidéo dans la même
phrase avec quelques-uns sa patte de
leurs biens c'est vrai
on est formaté stéréotypé par la société
en faisant un sportif c'est un rugbyman
un judoka football tous ces gens là sont
des sportifs pourtant quand on dit
qu'ils jouent aux jeux vidéo c'est plus
vraiment de sportif mais pourquoi vous
offre ces joueurs là s'entraîne qu'un
jeu vidéo et s'affrontent un jeu vidéo
mais ils ont les mêmes contraintes de la
part des clubs est la même la même
pression de la part du public et
structurer les clubs que grossir de plus
en plus investi de plus en plus d'argent
et ont de plus en plus de spectateurs
ils ont les mêmes pressions ils ont la
pression au niveau ils doivent gérer
l'alchimie entre temps de sommeil au
repos et bien entendu vie privée il veut
aussi souvent dans les gaming house qui
sont des maisons conçues pour eux où ces
cinq joueurs souvent de 2,5 ou toute
l'équipe vivent ensemble avec le coach
de manager donc très peu d'intimité vous
l'aurez deviné et beaucoup de questions
psychologiques
c'est très dur de tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps être au travail
surtout que le jeu vidéo elle fait pour
se détendre et d'ailleurs les sportifs
etc évolué ils font appel aux mêmes
besoins que les sportifs plus classiques
et des psychologues revient avec des
chasseurs de têtes qui vont chasser ces
joueurs là pour les trouver de plus en
plus jeunes et ils vont même jusqu'à
chasser leurs horreurs n'auraient pas de
santé puisque et à ses goûts et ses
envies dans certains pays comme
l'amérique et la corée
c'est déjà tout à fait leur place que
c'est un métier et ces joueurs là pour
vous donner un kit orchidées pour pour
les considère comme athlète faut savoir
qu'un joueur est cependant qu'un joueur
ea sports professionnels va être autour
de 400 actions par minute à une action
par minute c'est un clic sur une souris
ou sur un clavier ou dit c'est assez
facile nous sommes une personne normale
est capable d'en faire 150 quand vous
comprenez ça quand vous les voyez
personnellement j'ai eu la chance de les
voir en vrai là vous dise
je comprends mieux pourquoi c'est
considéré comme les athlètes je
comprends même pas qu'il en ait besoin
de s'entraîner une fois par jour
leur réflexe leur cardio la régulation
car oui on peut faire du on peut jouer
aux jeux vidéo et faire du sport
normalement c'est violent et c'est là
l'important c'est l'évolution de ce
métier
d'ailleurs il génère de plus en plus de
gens faut savoir que il ya cinq ans les
sports que ces quelques centaines de
personnes qui ont maintenant des
millions de personnes font des
placements dans des stades pour les
regarder les regarde à la télé je vous
ai dit pour la génération z le sport à
la télé c'est fini tout le monde me
regarde je lis porte moi le premier
j'aurais peut-être faire un peu de sport
et c'est là la particularité de ce
métier il faut que se développer donc
pareil pour ces joueurs là d'orthodoxes
et les personnes qui jouent aux jeux
vidéo qui gagnent de l'argent peu
enfreint conseillère à leur métier comme
des athlètes
ea sports dans le sport électronique
c'est un peu la réflexion que j'avais
envie de partager avec vous aujourd'hui
et sur cette fameuse question de s'est
pas vraiment métier au bassiste un média
j'ai pas forcément les réponses pour
vous d'ailleurs je pense peut-être
certains regourd déjà la leur mais
généreux en votre compagnie de partager
nos points de vue sur ce métier un peu
d'argent donc merci
[Applaudissements]